>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington D.C.
>> Kate Zwaard: Welcome to
the last presentation today
at the book festival.
I'm so excited to be hear
talking with all of you.
I hope you enjoyed yourself.
It was a busy exciting day, full
of authors and storytellers.
And they invited me here to close
out the program talking about some
of the innovative work that the
Library of Congress is doing.
So, I'm here today to talk to
you about this idea that we have
in libraries about using
collections as data.
So, as we collect more
digital material,
and as we digitize more paper and
tangible works, it's very easy
to put those up as exact digital
surrogates of the physical items.
But we'd like to think creatively
about what other possibilities
are inherent in these things?
And so, I'll tell you a short
story about using this concept
of using collections as data.
Starting with some of our friends
the very handsome founding fathers,
Alexander Hamilton
and James Madison.
So, if you, those of you who have
seen Hamilton or remember anything
about high school may remember the,
may remember the Federalist Papers
which were cowritten by John Jay,
Alexander Hamilton,
and James Madison.
And they were published under
a pseudonym Publius and to try
to persuade colonial citizens
to ratify the constitution.
And when changing public opinion
converted these documents magically
from anonymous trolling
to foundational documents
of the democracy, we started
to get a sense of authorship
of these papers, which founding
fathers wrote which ones.
After the dust settled, there were
twelve that remained in dispute.
Hamilton said that
Madison wrote them.
Madison said that he didn't
have much to do with them.
People generally thought
Madison did write them.
And why was there so
much finger pointing?
Well, these were propaganda
pieces and sometimes authors,
the authors took positions sort
of for the sake of argument
that they wouldn't have, different
from the positions
they had publicly.
So, historical opinion over
the years swung back and forth
about who wrote the papers depending
on who was in favor in time
and what pieces of historical
evidence were coming to light.
But, in 1944, historian Douglass
Adair did a comprehensive review
of the historical document
and determined
that Madison probably wrote them.
But he considered the
historical evidence modest.
So, he sought another way
of making an analysis.
I really love this quote.
He, Douglass Adair talked
with two statisticians to see
if there was a computational way
to distinguish the authorship.
So, Frederick Mosteller and David
Wallace were intrigued by this idea
and they decided to
take on the challenge.
They, and this quote is from the
first paragraph of their book,
which I encourage you to read if
the story sounds interesting to you.
It's very readable
and very interesting.
So, they decided to do, they decided
one way that they might be able
to distinguish authorship between
Hamilton and Madison would be
to count sentence length
and do an average.
So, they did this.
They took a set of known
Hamilton papers and a set
of known Madison papers and they
laboriously counted sentence length
and did some analysis.
For example, they had to decide
whether quoted sentences counted
toward the average.
And then they after this work
they came out with the answer,
and average sentence length
of 34.5 words for Hamilton.
And 34.6 words for Madison.
So, that was a bust.
And, next they tried
standard deviation.
So, they thought, even if
the averages are the same,
what if one author writes lots
of average length sentences,
and the other writes lots
of teeny tiny sentences,
and lots of really long sentences.
So, they went back, and they
did all the counting again,
crunch the numbers, and the
average standard deviation
for both authors was
nearly identical as well.
And it turns out they both were
schooled in a certain style
of writing that was popular at
the time, so if they had talked
with Dorian about this maybe they
could have gotten a head start
on the research.
But so that was kind of a bummer
and they shelved the project.
A few years later, the original
historian reached back out to say
that he found a tool
that might be useful.
He found that while
Hamilton uses the word while,
Madison uses the word whilst.
And that fact in itself is not
enough to discriminate authorship.
The word does not appear often
enough, it doesn't even appear
in all the Federalist
Papers that were in dispute,
but it gave them an idea
of somewhere to start.
So, the statisticians in
their lab counted word usage
in a screening set of known
Hamilton and known Madison papers.
And you can imagine how laborious
and exciting this would
be as a project.
So, they had a screening set, they
counted, they listed all the words,
they counted how often it came up.
And then they compared who
used what words more often.
And they determined which words
were predictable discriminators
against words which words they
called dangerously contextual
because they were associated
with the subject favored
by one author rather
than part of their usage.
And they ended up with
117 to analyze.
Using Bayesian analysis, raise your
hand if you're a fan of Tommy Bays.
Who doesn't love Tommy Bayes?
Using Bayesian analysis, they
determined the probability
of authorship based on the
number of times the words appear.
And like I said, if
you're interested in any
of this, please read the book.
It is a little bit heavy on
the statistics but it's fun
and readable and it's great.
So, they concluded, quote "Our
data independently supplement those
of the historian.
On the basis of our data alone,
Madison is extremely likely
in the sense of a degree of belief
to have written the
disputed Federalists."
And what I really like about this
is that none of this is digital.
So, when we talk about
collections as data,
it's really a concept that's
existed for a very long time.
We've been using, we've been
analyzing collections materials
as if they were data
for a long time.
But what's new now is that,
cheap and easy computing
democratizes this.
So, this is available to
curious people in their home
or to journalists and not
just available to you know,
professors with large
labs who and grad students
who can help do counting.
In this example, our heroes spent
years inventing this analysis.
So, this type of analysis
had never been before.
But a lot of that time was
in laboriously counting word
frequencies and in hand calculating.
And their data was
limited by human scale.
And what I'd like for you to
do is imagine what we could do
if we had computation and
cheaper data, and faster analysis.
So, to bring this story
around to Harry Potter,
which I think is important
to do in any talk.
This sort of linguistic
analysis has gone
from cutting edge to
now very common.
So, a few years ago, a computer
scientist Patrick Juola got a call
from a reporter who was reading the
new mystery writer Robin Galbraith,
and got a tip that
might be Harry Potter.
But he needed more evidence
to prove that that was true.
So, he asked the computer scientist
to do the same kind of analysis.
And the computer scientist
did and proved
that Robin Galbraith
was really Harry Potter,
and he did that in a couple of
days instead of a series of years.
And his code is now
available for anybody to use.
And that brings us back to today.
So, one of the things we're
exploring at the Library
of Congress is how we can
enable this sort of research
through the ways we're
providing collections,
through training, and
through events.
And we've hosted a series of
symposiums for people to come
and talk about their work
and talk about the challenges
and opportunities inherent
in computational analysis
of collections.
And if you're interested
you can Google that term
and you'll see the
summaries of those days
and also the talks are available.
So, I want to talk a
little bit about my group,
National Digital Initiatives.
We're very inspired by our
new boss Dr. Carla Hayden.
She's leading the Library
very strongly in a direction
of opening up the collections.
She talks about this place lovingly
like the American's
people treasure chest
that she's helping to crack open.
And we, and DIC see it as our
duty make this happen for digital
and digitized collections.
And I'd like to tell you about
a few things we're working on.
The first is crowd-sourcing.
So, we're working to expand
the Library's ability to learn
from our users to more
digital platforms.
And this is a screenshot of a
project that was built by Tom Wong
who is a developer at the
Library of Congress while he was
on a fellowship at my team,
National Digital Initiatives.
And this a tool, can we go back?
This is a tool that invites
the public to identify pictures
and cartoons in historic newspapers
and helps us caption
that, caption them.
This will give us two things.
Better findability, because
captions are historically do not,
optical character recognition
does not work very well on them,
but also will have a data set that
we can use to give to researchers.
So, if researcher is
interested, for example,
in World War I era cartoons,
we'll be able to serve that.
We're excited that we're going
to launch this in a couple
of weeks as a beta application.
So, please stay tuned and hopefully
you'll be able to contribute.
This isn't the only crowd-sourcing
project we're working on but some
of those details I'll
have to save for later.
But there are other, this is going
to supplement the Library's program
of crowd-sourcing including
Flickr, the American Archive
of Public Broadcasting Game,
and efforts in the Law Library
and World Digital Library.
Another thing we're working on
is a Congressional Data Contest.
So, our CIO, Bud Barton
announced this years,
at this year's legislative data
and transparency conference
that we'll be hosting a competition
for creative use of
legislative data.
And we'll be announcing more of
the details in a couple of weeks.
But, this will invite the
public to take legislative
and congressional information and
think of creative ways to analyze
or present that information.
And we're hoping that it
spurs people to interact
with the information that
we're making available,
an also with the legislative
and democratic process.
I'm really excited to
announce this next thing.
We are working to launch
labs.loc.gov in a few weeks,
which we hope will
be a place for play
and innovation with the collections.
It will be our home, NDI's home,
so you'll be able to follow some
of our work if that's what
you're interested in there.
And we'll host things like results
from our hack-a-thons
and fellowships.
And this a particular image of one
of our hack-a-thons
which I really like.
Are any of you programmers
in the audience?
So, for those of you who are not
programmers, you may watch movies
and programming looks like this.
[typing noises] But in real
life, it looks mostly like this.
And so, I think this is a very
good image of programmers at work.
A few more things.
I'd like to mention the Kluge
Fellowship in Digital Studies.
So, if you are interested in
academic research and would
like to do that at the Library,
and you're specifically interested
in studying the impact of the
digital revolution on society,
we invite you to apply
for a Kluge Fellowship.
The applications are due December
6th, so you have some time
to get your materials in order.
And more than one can
be awarded in a year,
so share it with your friends if
you think they might be interested.
Lastly, I want to mention a
program NDI's been working
on to bring exciting people
to Library of Congress
for short term, high
impact projects.
We call it the innovator
and residence program.
We're wrapping up some details
on this year's fellowship
and we should have
more to announce soon.
So, thank you for coming, and
thank you for listening to my talk
at the end of a very long day.
It's lovely to see all
your smiling faces.
It's just the cap on a
wonderful and exciting afternoon.
If you're interested in
the work that we're doing
in National Digital Initiatives,
please go to blogs.loc.gov/thesignal
and you can follow us there and
we'll be posting all of our new
and exciting projects
as we launch them.
And I'd be pleased to take any
questions if anybody has any.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Ma'am
Yeah, so the question is, instead
of doing targeted sharing are we
doing anything at the higher level
so making the Library of Congress
collections more broadly available.
And I think one of the
things I'm super excited
about with labs is we are having a
page on that called LC for Robots.
And it's, it will be a
listing of all the APIs
and book data that's available
from the Library of Congress,
along with contextual information.
So, you'll understand, I think
from the outsider's perspective
we have Chronically America,
which is this wonderful
website filled
with 12 million digitized
historic newspapers.
And we have loc.gov where you
can get prints and photographs
and manuscript collections.
And how do those two things
interrelate I think is very,
it can be very intimidating.
And also, it's hard for somebody
to get a comprehensive view.
So, I hope you'll check that out
and make some good use of it.
Does that answer your question?
Okay. Anybody else?
Yes.
>> What's your background?
>> Kate Zwaard: Oh, you know,
I'm sorry I should have introduced
myself at the start of the talk.
My name is Kate Zwaard,
I am the Chief
of National Digital Initiatives
at the Library of Congress.
And I started here as a programmer.
And I ran the repository development
group for awhile until I,
this new team was started,
and they asked me to lead it.
Anybody else?
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.